因為這週其實我左覺掌三件比較大的事情
就是第一個就是美聯儲上週表態以及聯儲可能後面的那個主席
因為現在討論非常積極的就Kevin Warsh能不能變成美聯儲後面的主席
然後他上來以後會對貨幣政策有什麼影響
因為記得我們之前在12月份的時候講過一期說美聯儲的火車已經使出戰了
後面不管是誰上台其實都不會有特別大的變化
因為上週的時候沒有特別去講這件事情
因為其實你看Polling Market預測聯儲主席
在上週的時候其實沒有人覺得Kevin Warsh能夠上去
其他幾個其實相對來說都比較各
Kevin Warsh比較出名的是他以前說美聯儲應該縮表這個言論
而且其實他是一個尖銳的聯儲擴表的批評者
一直是非常非常強硬的
所以當時帶到一句話上週我說如果Kevin Warsh萬一被選上去的話
那麼可能會對市場造成一些衝擊
那麼現在看來川普就是要選Kevin Warsh
那麼這個後續會有一個什麼樣影響
我覺得這是第一個事情
然後市場對於這件事情的反應其實不太一樣了
包括Rate Market 包括Acquity Market
然後還有黃金 白銀和比特幣
黃金和白銀比特幣總之來說的話是這樣的
越市散戶多的市場影響越大
那是黃金 白銀比特幣跌了很多
那黃金 白銀還有一些其他的原因
那麼第二個問題我們待會就會說一下
金和銀還有最近的這個上週的那個暴跌
以及1月份它為什麼漲了這麼多
這個是先貨避空嗎
先貨避空以後然後再是多頭包草
然後連著這樣兩波
那麼之後我會花大概15分鐘時間
說一下我對幾個模型的看法
因為股票市場它對這個東西的影響
還是不太一樣的
那麼不管聯儲政策怎麼樣
就等至上我還是覺得會很鬆了
然後接下去試想討論很多
包括從去年開始有很多人說
因為接著那個很多人講到Google
就谷歌
然後谷歌的模型是不是明顯的是好於GPT的
然後那個谷歌模型是不是明顯好於GPT
現在在牌桌上有哪些人
那AI之後的生態是怎麼樣
我這裡少了一個圖
其實就是現在Hatchfong的尺寸
對於那個Hatchfong
對於那個Software的尺寸軟件尺寸
和Hatchfong對於Sami的尺寸
這個減刀差很大
也就是軟件是一直在掉
大家不買軟件
然後大家一直在買硬件
那麼這個趨勢性會怎麼樣
以後軟件會走成什麼樣子
是什麼樣的一個生態
為什麼投資人做這樣的腳的投票
然後主要講一下四個模型的廠的不一樣
我把Grogg放上來
因為我覺得Grogg還是他有一個代表性
就是他雖然他應該把他弄小一點
就是他他不是在牌桌上
跟這三個是一樣的
但是他有他的代表性
有可能是有可能以後可以做一個黑馬
然後先說一下連處的政策
連處的話沒有降息
但是連處有一個明確的
我覺得連處的態度基本上是這個態度
就是現在市場的經濟數據
是不足以讓美聯儲停止去降息的趨勢
這個基本上就是美聯儲
在這一次之後的一個明確的表態
就是經濟數據在改善
但是我們的降息的趨勢是不變的
這次是不降
為什麼呢
因為短期的數據還不足以讓我們降
然後我們可以再去等一段通脹
然後這個是大概是美聯儲的態度
然後對於今年年底的利率
基本上委員們比較統一的
是認為是應該下降的
這個這個是一個就是說
趨勢性沒有變化
但是目前的經濟數據在改善
被認為是比較陰的
就是比較豪潰式的一次
那結合後面要上來一個
更加陰派的聯儲主席
市場現在擔心的就是
美聯儲的態度會不會變化
然後KAMEN WASH以前講過的那些
KAMEN WASH以前講過的那些
那個視頻
你們可以去翻一下
就是特別是他08年以後批評
那個白蘭基去擴表
然後他的意思就是
美聯儲不應該為市場買單
我們的所有的inflation物價上升
其實都是那個擴表造成的
他講的沒有錯
但是如果沒有擴表
就是沒有貨幣政策的配合的話
那那個我們就通縮了
這個事情他不討論
對我覺得KAMEN WASH的任命有幾個點
我說一下
因為這個確定性還是很高的
現在唯一阻撓他任命的
可能是參議院
參議院認為特朗普要降息
所以特朗普要降息
然後那個JPEL沒有非常配合
特朗普去降息
所以特朗普弄了一個刑事案件
說他在裝修美聯儲大樓的時候
有什麼問題
然後要司法部調查他
所以現在參議院要求
特朗普把這個case給drop掉
首先KAMEN WASH這個人是
特朗普推到那個參議院是能夠通過的人
排除了這件事情
排除了那個JPEL這個事情以外
他是能夠通過的
因為他外在看上去
其實並沒有KAMEN WASH沒有什麼問題
也沒有說他
因為特朗普一直說我要降息
如果你找一個非常非常各派的人
很容易在議院裡面受到阻撓的
他找個WASH這個人是個比較smart group
他確實是能夠在議會裡面被通過的
第二
我是認為當你在局外
就是你不當政的時候
你去拼頭論足的去直點江山
然後去質疑那個聯儲的政策
和自己真正當政的時候的政策
是會很不一樣
這個是一個
就是說現在聯儲本質上是要看經濟
和經濟基本面
不管是誰上臺
他還是要看就業情況怎麼樣
還是要看你的經濟增長怎麼樣
所以一個鷹派一點的主席
和一個表面上就是
以前發言比較鷹派一點主席
和以前鷹派非常哥的人
上臺以後做的事情就不會有什麼區別
這個區別不會特別大
就是這是聯儲的制度
第二就是聯儲的制度裡面
就是它是一個投票值的
為什麼JPOW主席每一次能夠吹得動票
因為它在那個美聯儲裡面有很強的聲音
或者說這個主席的苦練習非常好
他的信用非常好
大家能夠買他的帳
因為這個是大家投票
他不是說中國一個領導負責字
央行行長想把基礎貨幣給你翻一倍就翻一倍
這個在美聯儲是做不到的
因為有12個聲音
有12個人投票還換了投票
所以你主席一般說
他在開會之前是跟每個人都溝通了
溝通完以後大家再去投票
是有共識以後去投票
即使如此
JPOW在12月份強制性的去降息的時候
其實已經在委員會裡面面
有很大的阻斃
已經有decent了
我們叫decent就是有反對票
所以我使能夠脫離美聯儲的制度
和美國經濟的資本原因
然後去做一些事情
其實這件事情是比較難的
所以我們不要認為換一個主席
會有特別大的那個就是會不會特別大的意外
所以你會看到比方說
Dollarate沒有
你說你理論上來說
如果說是真的
那個覺得他要把國債權賣掉
要做QT了
我們把國債賣掉
等於是做QT
等於是做通貨
就做緊縮
就是什麼
Qualitative tightening
就做那個量化緊縮了
你要做量化緊縮的話
你的利率不得飛上去嗎
那個但是
其實國債市場沒有特別大的
沒有那麼大的影響
就是在過去一個星期
Kavin Wash被可能被任命以後
但相反
Iquid市場影響
就股票市場
那個黃金
阿比的利益那些東西
這些被下鳥了
散戶散戶散戶對這個事情的影響
因為Rate市場基本上都是機構投資人
所以Rate市場影響沒有那麼的大
然後這是兩個
那我說一個第三個可能
這是我個人的觀點
就是川普這個人
這個比較看出本手
你們就聽一下
就比較那個比較爭議性
就川普這個人選人
現在所有就是他選人的標準
只有一條
就是忠誠不絕對
絕對不忠誠
就你我他選人
現在只有一條
就是忠誠
誰跟我忠
我就能執行我的意志
我就選他
然後你執行我一直入境中間
我崩壞你執行入境中間
你把人給槍斃了
還是你再執行
我要去做
比方說艾斯
我要去做那個Border control
你把人給入場
直接給槍斃了
還是說你闖出天大的窟窿
我都給你兜著
你去衝到白宮
我給你
你去衝到博惠山
我給你上面掉
這個現在
我覺得他的態度比較明確
就是你反正跟著我
我就保著你
你不跟著我
我就告訴你
你其實你說
JPOP幹了什麼事情
JPOP不也降息了
他只是一個非常專業的人
他專業的人在於
你他就是覺得
基金經濟基本面怎麼樣
我就根據這個基本面量
降息或者不降息
他在川普任上的
上一屆任上的時候
他沒有去降息
所以川普耿耿於懷
就覺得我選輸了
你在裡面佔了三分之一的功勞
因為你沒有降息
那資本市場就不好
資本市場不好的話
那你就導致我後面
就選白人就選輸了
你後面根據經濟情況
你又跟財政部那個hand hand
就是手拉手
然後去降息
搞那個通脹
把通脹搞起來
跟著跟著白的
你就合作的很好
然後我上任之後
我又讓你講
其實你先又不講
就是特朗普這個人
本質是喜歡搞大水漫冠的
至少在自己認識上
他是要搞大水漫冠
他是要看到星星像龍
什麼東西
看上去長了很多的
股票double
他上次不在那個double
是說股票double
股票翻倍
他自己說的
所以他不太希望
就說那個
他覺得接票不聽話
然後你講你不講
所以呢
去搞了一個刑事案件
去整他
就是威脅他
那個理想也是被搞的
就是一樣的
美聯儲另外一個
忘記哪個聯儲的主席了
所以他在這種情況下
他去選一個橫陰害的人
跟他想去做的事情相反的
我覺得是不可能的
因為你要搞清楚
川普到底要的是什麼
他要的是放水
你錢很多
然後支持他搞那個AI
然後支持他把那個資本上
就是因為他經濟轉型的時候
是需要一個寬鬆政策的
這個是我們上個月
你去年底的時候
一直在說的事情
就是你在新製生產力
產生的過程中間
需要寬鬆的貨幣政策
去獲得資金
去取代救的生產力的
那麼在這裡面
他是需要一個
比較寬鬆的貨幣環境
他不是要短期利率
一定要降到多少
他是要一個寬鬆的貨幣環境
如果按Kevin Walsh
或市場上很多人猜測的是說
我讓Kevin Walsh去降息
同時的話收表
那他的結果收表的影響
是大於降息的
這個是必然的
所以市場應該是暴跌
所以這個事情是很難的
你哪怕你去收表
這個擴表在美聯儲2008年之後
其實大家everyone on board
也就是說每一個人都是
一起幹的這個事情吧
這麼講
就是大家一起幹這個事情
你上來要把桌子掀了
你在美聯儲裡面
你也幹不成
就是Walsh在美聯儲裡面
要做這件事情也非常難
所以為什麼川普覺得Walsh
這麼硬派的人
他卷一個人上來
Walsh肯定跟他表不太的
說我上來要幹嘛
這個事情一定是
根據領導的意志辦的
你們可以看看如今
你以前在對於中國和美國的
外貿的時候講到我的態度
後來上臺他辦了嗎
他沒有辦吧
對吧
Rubio
Macro Rubio
那個國務卿
你可以看看對共產國家
對於中國的態度是怎麼樣的
現在上來辦了
也沒有辦吧
就是這個都是川普的意志
而且川普希望美聯儲聽話
就美聯儲本來是獨立的
他希望他更加聽話一點
所以選一個人
我覺得大概就是選自家的Walh
為什麼說他自家Walh
你們可以查他的岳父是誰
岳父是創國的堅定的支持者
大學的同學
對
是岳父
不是父親
岳父
是他大學的同學
堅定的支持者
長期的捐還者
這麼一個人
所以你不管以前發出什麼樣的言論
他覺得你可靠
就自家Walh會聽話的
我覺得是這個態度把Walh選上來
那Walh選上來以後
我不太會去做特別特別過分的事情
然後大概有可能會繼續叫我要QT
但是QT不成之後
搞成了大規模的降息
然後搞成QE
因為你要QT
你要做一件什麼樣的事呢
QT
那個QT你做的事情相當於是
美聯儲在2008年以後
用公共部門的槓桿取代了私營部門的槓桿
這個是聯儲在過去幾十年做的一件事情
也就是原來我們在銀行的時候
那時候銀行很好
我們在銀行的時候
我的老闆Bonus可是50個命令USD
就是5000萬美元
那個年代5000萬美元
然後那個後來再也沒有這種好日子
為什麼呢
因為我們那個時候銀行槓桿很高
然後銀行槓桿很高
08年之後報了之後
他不讓你加槓桿
不讓私營部門銀行取代過的槓桿
因為說到too big to fall
那太大了容易倒
然後使得這個市場上的槓桿
是需要有人提供的
不然金融是沒有辦法流動的
我們的經濟的efficiency
我們講過
你的經濟增長需要維持的2.5%以上
然後這個2.5%
你是人口的增加
加上你的經濟效率的提高
這兩個加起來
在美國西方國家
現在在中國一樣的
沒有一個能夠達到2.5%
那你要到2.5%
你必須要印錢來達到
然後擴張資產負債表
你不讓銀行去增加資產負債表
來達到這個目的
你得自己去增加
所以美聯儲以前就自己增加
這個是大宏觀的邏輯
一直是這個樣子
那你現在到了
現在這一代
他們要做一件什麼事呢
就是說美聯儲資產負債表
那你可以繼續走下去
像日本一樣走到走到鏡頭
你也沒有鏡頭
日本到現在都沒走到鏡頭
可以一起走下去
中國是像中國一樣
拼命的硬
就是中國比日本還橫
你可以按照中國這樣繼續走下去
但是開放過去
他們想做的是說
好我要把聯儲的資產負債表
收回來
我公共部門能擴不了的地方
也收回來
那我收回來以後
誰去填補呢
那你用私營部門去填補
你把私營部門全部解綁
讓銀行的槓桿更加增加
然後去年的ESL還不夠
然後我可能把那些很多規定
給你全去掉
然後沒有特別to fall
to fall的時候
我再去救你
不來限制你
那麼私營部門的槓桿上去以後
可以把公共部門降下來
它搞不好公共部門不降
然後把私營部門
剛剛搞上去
把利率再搞下來
那就是大水漫灌
就是這個
這個我覺得是basic case
在我來看
就是Cabin Wars上去以後的basic case
因為其實我們的萬歲
也那個稅收的稅
也不太懂
就是對這個經濟
它在還有一個是這樣子
最後一個原因
我覺得它其實不管是上來
就Cabin Wars上去也是會比較割的
就是全世界沒有一個財政政策
可以獨立於貨幣政策去做
不負責
就是不負責意思
就是你那個財政政策
超過10%就三瓦
那以中國為例的話
中國是極不負責
對吧
因為我財政
你加上地方財政的拼命花錢
那地方財政拼命花錢的時候
如果央行把錢卡住
就是沒有支持任何支持的
所有地方政府全部破產
中國每一個地方
全部破產
那是必然的事情
因為這個就不多說了
我想中國為例要不要說歐洲
歐洲也是一樣
然後你的財政physical的擴張
背後的支持
一定是財政要去配合它的
唯一一次人類歷史上
試圖不配合
是歐債為期
也就是核心的那幾個國家
覺得我為什麼要配合你邊緣國家
去搞這麼多財政政策
你日子過得很好
然後我不給你
我沒有回購你這個地方貸款
然後我還要限制你的財政的額度
就是你吃這個額度
然後我決定可不可以回購你債權
因為我不回購債權
他們全死
然後保持歐債為期
以及歐債為期之後
為了控制財政政策
導致歐洲這些國家
承認了很多年
歐洲你看經濟過去10年
是一哈糊塗
然後跟美國的差距明顯拉開
神經10多年以前
我們覺得歐洲美國差不多
富裕程度差不多
現在完全不是一回事
接下來去10年更差
然後那話說回來
那麼在美國沒有這個問題
就是因為美國的財政和貨幣
都是一個就美聯儲
is never independent
我就說從來都不是independent
然後說是independent
其實從來都不是independent
然後那個
所以你美國再搞財政
貨幣擴張的時候
也就美國進入貨幣周期
歐洲再搞貨幣周期
中國日本也在搞貨幣周期
這個過程中間
是不會有獨立的央行的
獨立央行只會
就是包括日本
我們之前講過日本
你看著它央行要升息
然後財政要搞赤字
然後央行是不是會升息
它不會左手
它是右手的
它只有在一種情況下
會出現問題
就是通脹失控
就像阿里尼也說通脹失控
它被迫要升息
那麼我們就回來講
通脹會不會失控
現在通脹不會失控
首先通脹是一個非常
Lagging 非常之後的數據
它的比方說有三個部分在美國
一個是service
一個shelter
一個是房子
一個是product產品
service現在完全沒有看到
大規模的就業人不足
就像那個疫情拜登時期一樣
就說那個人用不了
人人不夠足
然後就業工資一天一個假
沒有發生這種事情
現在想法
你看到很多公司都在裁員
從科技公司到下面屯屯屯的裁員
因為腦力勞動者
我們現在七億腦力勞動者
要被這些模型給取代掉
我模型的事情可能放下周假
今天時間不一定夠
我把它放下周去假
然後要被模型取代掉
然後
所以在這過程中間
我們沒有看
第二個就是shelter
shelter是需要時間的
shelter的時間是18個月
就是你一般簽約
你簽房租的約
你簽後面簽18個月
簽一年後兩年
所以你就房租要漲價
你也要等房租租業到滿
所以其實它的這個 lagging 更強
就是需要很長的時間
你即時現在大規模
搞了一塌糊塗
你年底搞了一塌糊塗
它27年通常都起不來
然後第三個就是那個商品
商品中間有一個很大的因素
是中國
中國現在在一個嚴重的債務週期裡面
然後這個債務週期它只會催斷
就是它會忽然因為
應了太多的基礎貨幣
導致它一下子爆發
就是一下子物價狂漲
工資不漲
然後催斷
像強度威力
但是這個時點不太可測
你今年反正不太會搞出這種事情的
就是它要催斷
是會非常嚴重的
但是本質上中國是一個
極大的通縮因素
就是它的產品是個通縮
因為它東西便宜嗎
它捲了
它中國勞工還是很捲
中國還有這麼多失業了
這些失業的人不都是
對吧
都是苦力
都是等於幫你們幹活的苦力
降低你通脹的苦力
所以這個裡面
讓美國的通脹起來很難
所以在這種情況下
我覺得是本質是
美聯儲不是獨立的
沒有
它絕對不會獨立於財政部
它不是獨立於Trashree
它Trashree要大規模
要去做赤字的時候
央行是很難做獨立的
而且現在說過一句政治的事情
就是現在川普身邊的人裡面
川普身邊的人裡面
那個最最貝塔欣是Belton
你看
所有出來談判也是Belton
就是跟中國談判
不知道為什麼搞的也是Belton談
然後各種事情
都是Trashree Secretary Belton在做
所以Belton has Trump's air
然後能夠支持一個
跟自己完全不一樣的人上來
做美聯儲主席
我覺得很難
所以最終我覺得
Kamal Wash不用特別擔心
那回來看那個利率的市場
利率市場沒有特別大的反應
所以我們上周講到
Dollary and Carried Trade不會Bust
Dollary and Carried Trade不會Bust的原因是
你要看這個整體利率
它是漲得很快
你得看它的Volatility波動率
那個美元上一周
其實
然後再加上美元和日元的利息
那美元上周是跌了
那跌的原因
其實是日本要好像去干涉
日本老子好幾次要干涉
所以並不是市場導致日元有很大的波動率
而且日元的Rate在
日元利率在Stabilizer變平穩
這種過程中間
你要讓Carried Trade在後面時間
我覺得很難
那麼說一下
既然利率市場沒有很大的影響
那為什麼
黃金和白銀狂跌
就是你要想一下他為什麼狂漲
就是他狂漲的原因
是因為現貨Squiz
就是現貨Bicom
川普在1月份的時候
說他要對Precious Metal就是那個金屬
所有的這些
他覺得重要的金屬要爭關稅
美國本身也產了
然後你從外面進口要爭關稅
那你想LME的交易
白銀和黃金
白銀為例
白銀當然用到很多地方
它實際有大量的使用
從那個光能發電那些都有使用
你剛剛說你炒電力
你很多人也去炒銀
但這中間炒的金數很大
那麼是這樣子
就是說你白銀
而且炒的時候有很多ETF成立
ETF買了
就是存在那裡
等於是你那邊存的那些銀
是我ETF的
對吧
然後因為特朗普說
他要去搞一個關稅
搞完這個關稅以後
那個有很多人
把白銀從英國去論到
就Physical的
夠的
從LME給提出來放到美國去了
因為大家為什麼提營呢
因為怕他到時候營
你營到美國去要提關稅了
所以把營給提出去
那把營提出去以後
那你現貨的營在LME就不夠了
然後ETF就ETF又在持倉
這種情況下
就是使得市場對於單位買入
它的影響就是比過去大很多
你想
原來
這個是狗子們做的一個線性的回歸
就是原來一個1000噸級別的白銀
然後對LME的影響大概是2%
然後後來大概是7%
就是LME就是現在
就是B空以後
1000噸的影響是7%
你想2%的影響時候
那個時候
2%影響的時候
那個銀價還比現在要低
實際對於notional的支持
你相當於原來可能是30塊錢
影響2%
現在你120塊錢
影響7%
買1000噸
所以這個影響是被完全加劇的
再加上有很多ETF
那麽使得這個銀價就長了
就非常非常厚
然後黃金有類似的原因
黃金跟白銀其實是一起在漲
然後黃金中間
還有很多央行在買
就中國央行在一路得得得得在買
那暴跌
另外CME把銅管給加上去
就是在大家討論Caven Wash
有可能會被任命這個聯儲主席
然後它又是一個比較就極其
叫發言是極其硬派的那個人
那麽Caven Wash去聯儲以後
加上你現在要把保真金的比率提高
保真金比率提高是直接去銅管
所以導致這個金價
銀價直接去銅管
同時的話把多頭一路打爆
那好像昨天晚上
其實已經有一些反彈了
我今天早上沒怎麽看
其實昨天晚上也有一些反彈
要等到這個clearance結束
就是這一波的那個這個清倉全部結束
然後我是覺得白銀確實是有實際需求的
黃金是央行的實際需求更大
然後你要求PBOC準備幹嘛
要跪那個
你問中國人民銀行要準備幹嘛
然後那個
但是白銀是有實際需求的
然後但是這中間有一個問題
美國的Tariff是不會等過的
就是川普很難真的把白銀放進去加Tariff
現在把銀移到美國去的這個過程
其實是對Tariff的擔心
對關稅擔心
但是後面他不太會真的加這個關稅
所以我不覺得後面還是會這樣一條線
就是你可以說營有實際的需求
這個東西就好像你現在說
新那個存儲有實際需求
存儲肯定有實際需求
然後確實缺貨
缺到手機都造不出來的
現在就是二三線手機出貨量可能要減半個四十
我覺得四五十還是
然後蘋果這些不太受影響
那你手機買不到卡
你就要出貨
把那個Consume原來穿的全部搞死掉了
然後那個連車都出不了貨
但是他確實是有需求
但是後面他也在互產
所以後面我覺得是一樣的
就是一個波動的
如果是上漲也是一個波動的上漲
不是這樣一個沒有波動率的
然後直線的這個趨勢
然後說一下
美股的一些倫理吧
最後說一下
我把模型放下之後說
然後我覺得這還是挺重要的一個東西
就是大家對模型是怎麼理解
對於軟件是怎麼理解
Technology sector業績都也都不錯
就出來業績之後
其實大家股票都跌了
然後這中間有一部分的原因
其實你可以看
搜發大家預期2010%
然後其實跑到10%
這個是對二五年
26年的2010預期其實也是非常好
所以我們就本質上來看
我們看到特別是Tax sector
半導體 sector
那個Earning growth是在今年還是非常確定的
然後第二個就是
我們從Earning裡面看到的就是CAPEX
CAPEX就是投資
就Happers-Gallowed-CAPEX
CAPEX-Gallowed-CAPEX
那個我預期是會繼續找
從現在公佈
就是你在公佈Earning之前
大家覺得它會投5400億
公佈Earning之後
這一期它又變成了5600億
5600億對於二五年失敗
就將近40%不到38%的增長
然後我覺得這個全年增長還是會增加的
就是現在所有做financial model的
都是認為我的CAPEX是在表而說
30左右的增長
20 30的增長
但它其實全年跑完以後
它的這個增長會到45%
它就會更高
然後這個我覺得是一個大趨勢
就是說我們現在看到
就是在半導體裡面
營利沒有營利還是非常好
然後第二就是在半導體裡面
那個CAPEX的投入還是很堅決
那麼不管就一個最最極端的例子
就是那個Oracle
Oracle被市場一起做控
全市場做控它
然後認為它那個CAPEX做得過多了
然後融資融資融了很多
然後先經流二八年才回來
然後後面的客戶就是歐盟AI
然後就去做控它
那麼在這種情況下
它都不會back down
現在其實這些國家就像戰國七雄一樣
改革是有陣痛的
你要去買卡就買個改革是有陣痛的
但是不改革你就死掉
就是你在軟件行業裡面
就不你不去做AI你就死掉
因為這個大家都看到是整個行業的變化
所以華爾街有時候
現在短期裡面他可能不怎麼相信AI
但是這個沒有辦法
你做一個公司你客服他
所以Oracle你就出來融資
就昨天到上一期的消息吧
應該是融了200億的股票
然後一共做了大概好像是500億的融資
50個變略50個變略的融資
然後把這個50個變略融資
繼續去投CAPEX
他哪怕把手上的東西賣掉
他也要去投CAPEX投AI
所以我這個就是華爾街的一個態度
我覺得華爾街現在對於AI的投資
這個態度是極其極其精
規模的態度是非常非常堅決
那華爾街現在還在質疑
但是那個我們會看到
今年會看到一個很不錯的而已
然後和CAPEX
然後這樣吧
我把那個關於AI和模型
我已經準備了
我前面可能講時間太長
關於模型的東西
我們放下周再說吧
好
看看大家有什麼問題